he made up his mind he was absolutely
determined to live that makes sense does
it not [ __ ] yeah because if you go Oh no
you're it's done yeah you're done yeah
15 now you go there must have been you
go 15 hours everybody when I was in
rehab they're every like just stacks of
mail every day just I don't even know
how they found out where I was
everybody's letter was the same
everybody's letter goes hey when I was
25 I got a DUI and got fired everybody
had been to the bottom when I was in
rehab and Sam Hunt which is a buddy if
he's a country singer got a DUI and I go
we got to talk to we got to find him and
we gotta tell him to stay on earth when
I was at the bottom everybody knew they
go I know what that feeling is and they
go I'm compelled to find where this guy
is on this planet and there was like my
sister was like getting notes from
friends that were like co-workers they
were like if it made me cry they go if
you know John
to help find him yeah and tell them yeah
and that saved my whole life yeah it's
the fighter and the kid had to run it
back
in when it was Brandon when it was
brightening but it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it right cause we coming at you
locked back with the team had to keep it
all G must see TV yes we did cause we
back at it again
fire
back at it again
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
John Chris
Chris go go with the intro that we sent
over John's uh
yeah
you guys he's very very funny and and uh
but it's not him doing it it's holy
ghost power that's right that's what's
working through yeah it's his higher
power the students between us you have
Jesus I have Satan but you guys both
yeah no you said you when your son was
having the seizures you were praying
before fights I pray who's that is that
Neil Brennan that has a joke he's like
he's like the most the most to be an
atheist is the most White Privilege
thing ever 100 like you got something
better than this I doubt it
dude
he's so [ __ ] buddy yeah I I now this
is going real well I I did I was
thinking about that a lot of people that
I know that are really arrogant atheists
are kind of had very cushy lives well
that shit's really busy well that's my
theory on people that are like we're in
a simulation like really that's the lady
making uh hamburgers at Burger King
simulation well five kids
get me out of here even a simulation
only rich people say something but
somebody's got to be controlling the
stimulation so for me like a simulation
doesn't need to really preclude God it
might just mean it might just mean it's
more knowledge we'll figure out but it
still doesn't get you closer to the idea
of somebody created all that but you've
never heard a broke person like die on
that Hill like this is a simulation it's
always like Elon Musk yeah
I mean country music country music is
like very like uh White like uh
religious yeah and it goes like one of
the best country songs is everybody
wanna go to heaven but nobody want to go
now meaning like but then you remember
like the the black gospel songs are
always like when we get there when we
get there so like this this is not good
yeah but yeah because they were when
they were slaves and they were singing
these songs it's like this is horrible
but we have hope in yeah but we know in
the future and countries like we'll get
there yeah they're like it's great right
yeah
it's something about getting older is
humbling in a way too yeah going through
[ __ ] and I I think that I think it's
interesting too that most of the
atheists I know are super into longevity
like yeah everybody I mean look
everybody wants to live fingers crossed
but bro people are doing all kinds of
stuff like they just turn their body
into a pharmacy and I'm sure there are
drugs let me tell you it's still gonna
be a losing bath all the time all the
time ten eight rounds oh dude I live you
might be a hard Donna down 10-6 remember
remember like you want to be 90 and then
100 and 110 that's not a great time
with uh children what's that do you know
any atheists with children not many well
don't open your eyes I mean there are
there are but I I know I'm just saying
there are but yeah remember nine eleven
like 9 12. everybody was like God what
year
2001 so okay
everybody was like let me do that hold
on hold on what year you American bro
that's a joke dude Zach was that uh he's
doing Red Carpet and it was on 911 and
they go when you think of 911 what do
you think of his what year
great joke it's so funny everyone else
is laughing the lady was not laughing
but every everybody was PR that you
gotta with that amount you saw it right
because it's in another country or
sometimes but you we saw it yeah and we
go people jumping out of it and you go
there's got to be something else
everybody's praying you know what I did
well I never forgot when I saw the tower
coming down I was on the phone with
Patty Jenkins and what's his name was in
there the the comic what's that the
comic that was in there oh wow I'm so
sorry
damn Steve never bounced back from that
he didn't no man I like Steve I I like
Steve too Steve's like one of the nice
guys in the world made a mistake yeah I
made a mistake he got caught on that lie
and then he was like I don't want to be
the guy who just made up a story and
then he had to run with it that one that
one was bad because he made a mistake
and then when you mess with like
American and 9 11 like terrorism yeah
they would rather you when they call you
a war proprietor but he never I don't
think he's ever I don't even think he's
doing the road anymore I think Steve is
yeah
because I when I was in uh Milwaukee
doing that theater out there and he and
he was doing a show that's so funny
because we all like we kind of know each
other like
like
in like we all kind of know of each
other's career like secondarily for sure
right guys all right so he's yeah he'll
be okay good yeah
I'm glad it's zany's weekend yeah yeah
but remember at that time he was on that
show he paid his prices in 2015. he's
been
yeah it was used on that show where was
that show he was a huge show
uh no no I was called Steve yeah
I never saw it but we were talking about
the the what what like I went to because
I've been canceled myself but I went to
a I did a show at a prison like a
Maximum Security Prison it's like with
the church like an Outreach she looks
special there no I should like what's
his name Joey diesel yeah yeah yeah but
I go I was almost kind of
um envious of those guys in there
because they did it and they go here's
the price and they go cool so I'll just
pay this price and then I'm back out but
like for like
any kind of infraction that all three of
us have it like what's
what what should the price be oh my God
among some people decided yeah there's
no Redemption and by the way it's not
even that I I don't need retention it's
like I'm good well it's also like if
you're guilty it's one thing yeah yeah
you know also that [ __ ] you so that yeah
yeah that's the other thing it's like
can you not just swear sorry dude I
apologize
my cars didn't work on so I had to drop
it off someone so I had to take Mike's
car to go get some food I'm driving out
and he's pulling in I'm in Mike's old
RAM and he sees me and I'm like oh this
isn't my car this oh God damn it I
thought you were different and when I
said God damn I was like oh I told Marco
he's religious I messed up dude when I
say around my grandma it shakes
John's like he said God my faith is
shaking yeah what if John went like this
I'm good no just keep going they're nice
yeah I heard what you said I'm not doing
the show oh yeah I'm gone I'm gone grew
up in the church yeah my dad's a
preacher still is yeah now now he's a
republican uh politician oh oh wow yeah
what's he do he said well he was he ran
for he just lost in the election above
for uh state house no he's from Georgia
though
don't go into politics they're gonna
they're coming for you how will someone
like hey Herschel uh you know what they
do when you become a politician right
yeah he's gonna have some baggage I'm
gonna risk it yeah I'm fine
abortion stuff he's like not a big deal
yeah I think he's yeah he still might
win his son's a very gay Republican yeah
really but he doesn't like him right son
doesn't like witches because I guess he
wasn't a dad his son has all the sugar
in the tank no I know but yeah but that
that's got to be it's that's got to be
when your son goes bad on you publicly
like that and he's in your same party
yeah same political party damn yes then
I go like this I go how what what did
you do as a father here what's going on
no he was a bad guy yeah and he has
another son that he's just never met
like listen you're not vote on him
because he's a good dad but everybody
gets like that like a yeah but there's a
lot of there's a lot of uh people on the
right like the alt-right they're like
remember like Candace Owens yeah she
said like kind of something and then
everybody rallied around it was like
five years ago everybody goes yeah and
then you kind of just become that yes
you kind of just that's what you get
your thoughts that's what you got love
from or like yeah and then you just
become that yep like he made some like
out-of-pocket statements and then
everybody's like yeah
whatever you've seen everybody do
there's a lot of comics that kind of
just
did a thing got attention for it and
then I'll just keep going down yeah this
is my angle so you you grew up in
Georgia but then once you started uh
doing stand-up you're doing open mics
and yeah like I started it Comedy Works
Yeah
Wendy yeah she started she gave me my
start I love the first comic ever uh
first Club to ever passed me really yep
when I did like to headline like the
local Comics the headline off night it's
like 250 I'll never forget this 250 is
how much and then I sold it out South
Club
oh right when I started like becoming
popular like in 2017 and Jeff remember
Jeff the black guy gay black guy that
was that run the club down there yeah he
came in and it goes when he wants to
give you this and it was to check for
four thousand dollars yeah and I never
forgot that
because in essence she goes hey it's 250
bucks but damn you how great fair is
fair yeah yeah yeah so that wasn't fair
right so what I mean he could have gave
me more no sold out hey hey yeah
about this I'm just saying that she came
in and gave me 500 deals she gave me she
gave me 250. she's selling it out for
five minutes she gave him four that's a
good that's a nice great I gotta check
this at the size of that check hey Wendy
I was just going over this story with
Brandon maybe let's take a little break
because we're talking one of the Lord's
children here yes okay so a little break
little respect here okay yep I've been
converted just converted I'm still on
the fence but if you want to enter my
cult that's fine
I still like money
you know there's a big UFC UFC 282 this
Saturday Daddy because we're doing a
fight campaign for it and before that
there's a fight campaign for rough and
rowdy Friday December 9th rough and
rowdy bar stool collabing with thick Boy
network baby 5 p.m Pacific Theo Von Don
Cerrone Rampage Jackson myself and
Saturday 7 P.M Pacific live on thick boy
UFC 282 Cal bass fight campaign Brian
count Sam tripley huge guest and myself
it's all going down now we're going to
watch the fights and then you can watch
fights and place a little wager on it
there you go we fancy ourselves some
batters your boy I owe you some money
pal well I paid but I always owe you
money yes so whatever but listen if you
want to watch the fight Pain and bet on
UFC 282 do it with my friends at
draftking Sportsbook the official sports
betting part of the UFC this Saturday
Saturday new customers can bet just five
dollars pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and get 150 in free bets
if they do check this out right now
everyone can earn up to fifty percent
boost when he plays the same game parlay
on UFC 2 82. listen there's a lot of fun
parlays on here you could parlay my uh
Mega Madoff and you could do Patty
pimlet you could do it with uh Darren
till potsinibio you could do all that if
you want to do just the favorites you do
Bryce Mitchell duplicies Patty pimlet
and magamed and you go and Sizzler if
they win they're the favorites but if
you're gonna bound the favorites that's
your best bet but parlay them so you
make more money and they boost your odds
it's that easy all right so download the
app right now use promo code fighter bet
five dollars pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and get 150 in free bets
if they do that's code fighter this
Saturday at draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
minimum age eligibility restrictions
Supply she show notes for details Yoshi
listen two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 more than 50 million men
in the US suffer from male pattern laws
like me
and is there anything out there is there
somebody like Jeeps keeps keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors wow there are only two FDA
approved medications that can prevent
hair loss taken from me keeps offers
both okay they offer a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your hair you
get a convenient virtual doctor
consultation and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
so you don't have to leave your home 24
care and support 24 questions low cost
ready for this if to keep that being you
got ten dollars per month keeps offers
generic versions the two FDA approved
medications to prevent your hair from
leaving yep they are affordable and
that's a huge difference yes remember
prevention is key kids treatments can
take four to six months see results so
act fast when it comes to your hair save
more spend less if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com fighter to receive your
first month free that's k-e-e-p-s.com
to get your first month free keeps.com
fighter it works if Mark Cherry was
telling a story he created Desperate
Housewives yeah he was sleeping on his
mom's couch yeah and uh and his mom gave
him some money and and he writes
Desperate Housewives basically on her
couch right and he said uh he was handed
he he was handed four years later five
years later he was handed a check for
103 million dollars and that was just
the first check was he still on his
mom's couch no he's not he gave his mom
500 bucks yeah I was like hey you give
her 400 bucks first chat he was just
like he and he looked at his mom and he
goes this is all because of you and she
goes I knew what horse I was betting on
geez you know this is not it wasn't
anything to me I knew I talked to her
that's a lot 103 000 million dollars
what do I do with that I fly differently
I'm still doing stand-ups go first class
yeah
I don't know even 103 stuff you're not
gonna own it right you probably don't
know
your rent you rent uh you rent space
yeah yeah hey but at 103 you are taking
photos oh man do you know the photos on
the private jet guy yeah yeah that's
always a tough sell oh I know I think
black Comics can do it better agree
black Comics are allowed too it's a
weird Flex
everyone's like f you you're like dude
you're using up too much fuel you
[ __ ] [ __ ] like Kylie Jenner and
and uh Travis Scott they have so much
[ __ ] because they took separate Jets
you're profoundly selfish all right all
right hey you know what you're right I
know people who fly privately and they
keep it a big secret yeah because if
they it's like like against their brand
yeah like because like a an athlete or
like a a musician yeah you want them to
be a rock star lifestyle but like blue
collars like we're sitting here at a
restaurant people coming ah what's up
dude look at this like words them yes
one of the people if we're doing it
right I think now the black Comics can
do it better they can they can they
celebrate it if I'm on Southwest people
be like what are you doing Southwest
it's not good luck the easiest flight oh
yeah
he's a man of the people yeah yeah look
at him yeah he's one of them if I can
avoid TSA [ __ ] shuttles all that stuff I
I I hate flying so much I hate it I hate
it horrible I almost Panic you went down
to Florida I just got back
well let's see I woke up at 6 55 Florida
time which of course is 3 55 my time
then you got to take an Uber all the way
to Fort Myers that's a good 45 minutes
yeah and then I gotta go to um well then
I gotta go to Atlanta and then I gotta
wait for an hour daddy didn't have a
direct waking up on the all flight days
I'm about to fly back home to Nashville
but all flight days are brutal no
they're brutal yeah is there is there a
spot if you
was it would be a bad look if you were
in it's in the 300 section at the Laker
game
would you go or no right he wouldn't
even go yeah yeah but I did
I did feel a weird type of way when I
went with Jeff dying he's like Mr Laker
like he knows that Jenny bust yeah and
we're on we're in her seats next to her
and the players are coming up saying
what's up and he's like are you gonna
take a picture like I don't think so
take a picture to post yeah I was like I
don't think that's not my that's not my
look yeah I don't know it's not we went
to my family bought like a like a the
Monster Jam like the monster trucks and
we have a family of like you know 30 a
bunch of kids so the whole
block is in the up there yeah and I go
oh man because then they're gonna be
like oh he's [ __ ] he's falling off it's
cheap yeah yeah he's not so you but you
don't want to be Courtside either
because they're like oh you're better
than us did you rally everybody out real
quick hopefully everybody's having fun
don't tag me in pics right do not text
me
Uncle John is there a celebrity you take
a picture with
we talked about this before that I mean
I people like come follow our tour bus
mostly women usually who follow the tour
bus around for like our lives are
different I go
I go is it your hair or your eyes mine's
just that now it's crazy blue how long
was it in to get a compliment from man
sorry no I just when you're tall that's
a record John's so much taller person
he's so much taller and his eyes just
you know those girls aren't fast enough
to catch your car I have hairy jeans
yeah but I wish don't you that when you
see somebody like it's a rabid fan like
that I go I wish I cared about something
that much yeah I wish I loved uh the
Portland Trailblazers to follow or the
Nascar or I know Iggy Azalea pitbull or
something I don't care about anything
maybe it was a really old celebrity that
was gonna die soon maybe
Don Rickles it would have to be someone
with live touring dates so you could go
to all of them who would you file like
I've never Springsteen you took a
picture with him okay and post or not I
was backstage with him and I and I he's
like such an artistic hero of mine so I
yeah somebody it was I yeah I took I
took a picture and I I really wanted one
that's the only time I've ever really
wanted you know the last time I was
worried to take the picture but I was
working for Showtime I was doing a press
conference and I'm sitting there and I
and I hear hey man you think Connor
really has a chance I'm like you know
what and it was Drake and I was in
Toronto yeah okay yeah he's my fave yeah
and I was like uh can I get a pick yeah
he's like yeah of course like oh he was
so friendly of course yeah during
college fight oh right and everybody
usually up there everybody up there is
the most friendly for the most part the
most like people that are just like down
here but yeah foreign
but you're just kind of like
throwing in the towel like like would
you ever do it to another comic yeah no
not enough [ __ ] million years I'm
really good friends with Rogan I'm not
gonna ask a picture but if somebody like
there's somebody asks that's you're
admitting to Drake that you're up here
um if you ask honestly out of respect
yeah yeah what if Drake was like can I
get a photo with you are you serious no
you got to act cool though spiders
yeah you get you got like you had Robert
Downey Jr Will Smith come up to yeah
yeah Fighters pick Fighters are kind of
famous to actors actors I'm trying to
say well can I get a pick with the
fighter not the comedian sorry just for
the record yeah
the fighter side
no I would uh if we do a show like in
The Green Room certain Comics who they
might be my friends but I love them I'll
get pics of that but can we get yeah
like Bill Burr's my like my I think the
best comic doing it so far is there uh
but he that's not a that's not an
admission like Springsteen he's like hey
I'm you're here I'm here it's just part
of my history like I just Pacino those
guys are part of almost why I became an
actor yeah and you ever you ever have
somebody that rolls with your crew that
you're like is this is not the time but
they're like with somebody up there and
you're like I want to ask them please
don't yeah please don't do this yeah
because they're with you so my my I had
my 50th birthday party and I was at your
house yeah broken it's broken broken
siren
and he's got some social anxiety doesn't
like it in yeah
one of my old friends you know since I
was 18.
walks up and goes
and Robin goes what are you doing
there's a great house your buddy yeah he
goes what are you doing what are you
doing
he just walked away and I was like oh no
that was bad that's a tough move it's
not good that's a tough then you go hey
we can't you can't in your own house
yeah that's a tough move I had um I I
had a
I've had some situations where I had I
had a party birthday party and a very
famous movie star was there yeah and
another friend [ __ ]
another friend
started pitching her oh no no no
oh man so bad and then another famous
person who was there came up and said
you need to get your friend in check
because he's pitching this very famous
famous person like this famous man
there's movie star yeah and and has got
her cornered and it was and I literally
ran over and goes hey hey I literally
went like so I go this is not the time
sorry no in my pitch no I was it was
cool but I was just I was mad man that's
tough I was mad there's a there's calm
I'm trying to think any comics for you
no I mean well like Chappelle and
everybody when I used to host it at
Comedy Works they would always come
through and I just some reason I knew I
go if you say can I get a photo that's
you saying like that's a kind of like a
they're not obviously because they're
much much bigger but like that's a
co-worker of yours yeah kind of we're
kind of and they're going to view you in
that way if you because when a Comics do
a guest spot for me on my shows because
I get a pick yeah
I'll do it I was in I was in Philly and
uh
with my wife and I'm Affiliated gas
station late at night and the guy goes
that guy goes and I'm like oh here we go
yeah yeah yes oh no Mr Stamo Stanhope
can I get a picture
hi dad you got to and then later on he
made my sandwich he goes you're not duck
stand up you're Brian count I [ __ ] up
good for him he goes like I go do we
yeah cool that's a good Instagram I love
dogs man there's a guy uh Trey Kennedy
Trey Kennedy's uh comic sketch comic
does a lot of stand up too we look very
similar bring that up chin and then we
Trey Kennedy and then uh people come up
to me and say hey I love that uh middle
schoolers bit you do and that's his bit
oh [ __ ] and I go I just I'll just go
thanks man you don't want to argue it
man
oh no dude yeah
dude I was at a charity golf tournament
with Tim Tebow and people thought I was
Aaron Hernandez
while he was like on trial there's
pictures of me up there I look like me
there yeah that's not me well I don't
know yeah and we do we both are similar
like characters if you guys were a gay
couple I would be like those guys are
narcissists because they're dating each
other
he's a little thicker than you but he
then he got in shape and he looked even
more like you yeah kind of like kind of
like a yeah she's like a thicker version
like yeah he's too big to be keep
yourself nice and trim yeah I tried to I
knew I was coming on here is that what
it was yeah
there's no there's no liver King uh
allegations about me I don't know
because I'm looking at you are you
that's all Maddie yeah all natural all
right remember can you and I were
talking about this you know because
obviously on my stance took some heat
from it but I was telling chin on the
shop show it's like
you and you sent to me you're like hey
because we did we didn't know the liver
King prior to it like yeah you and I
never do that so we didn't see the we
didn't when Derek from years ago more
plates more dates did the thing Adam I
was like oh that's messed up but then I
even uh sent Derek a DM about it but you
got to realize like when liver King
walked through I was like let me look
him up real quick he's funny he's a
character it could be a fun show yeah
and then you start nice that was
actually true and he was so nice to us I
was like this guy's great but he is nice
he's a nice voice I think like somebody
I think uh somebody was asking Bill Burr
I think Chrysler asked Bill Burr like do
you ever want to meet the president and
he goes no because if I meet him I can't
light him up yeah because it's such a
good point I ever met somebody that you
go oh he's nice
everybody no that's my entire career
yeah
on food truck diary with the fighters on
and then they fight and I'm like you
can't he's my boy got both of you guys I
was like oh I met him they're nice yeah
I hate us before you're like I gotta
quit making this YouTube and burner
accounts if we fight you're gonna so we
better not see those comments on Reddit
but yeah here's how how do you feel I
want to talk to you about this but did
you see did you follow this liver king
drum yeah so I like I I saw his apology
yeah I didn't like his apology huh I
didn't like the apology I I but at the
same time like if you're gonna apologize
like that I'm gonna go all right my
thing about it was this my thing about
it was I think what happened was he got
really famous he was already making like
two weeks yeah he's already making a
fortune which people hate my biggest
thing for him would be this I I think
how did you think you weren't can how
did you think you could get away with
yeah that blatant about the lie like I
didn't realize he was denying it to that
point I thought he was important but
then he was like yeah I didn't know then
I saw him and I was like people that
were on but how do you know that's not
gonna catch we all know
like The Rock has done a very good job
of avoiding that subject well we know
well he's also a politician with it yeah
yeah but do that you'd be like but this
is my thing with the liver cancer it's
like I know him from I met him face to
face had a conversation we text you know
every week still we go back and forth
yeah well not lately but uh you know
really nice guy great great dad yeah so
then
I assumed everybody knew who's on
steroids when he came out I was like
this isn't a big deal it is a big deal
and then when I defend me I realized I'm
not defending that he lied I'm defend
him as a human being yes and he made a
mistake all good he needs to own up to
it and then carry on here's what if you
think you're gonna tune into this show
and I'm gonna Dogpile on this hate and
let's get rid of them no you no here's
what I appreciated though about the like
when when you read the the emails yeah
he actually takes his own supplements
that's a plus for me he takes his own
supplements that that's amazing you're
making 100 minutes you're actually
taking your own [ __ ] yeah like I got I I
can get with that like that's that I
appreciate he does eat the way he
preaches he does so and and he works out
twice a day like a [ __ ] maniac and he
does do sun gazing he does the sun is
balls he does all that [ __ ] Jin like a
great point so chin goes in a way it's
not that we would know but yeah do you
know anybody who's like buying his
supplements or do it like he's more of a
character on YouTube like he's a
character but if you do if like if like
Barry Bonds or like he hit 90 home runs
well without the supplements he'd hit 75
yeah like yeah he's still a number
really good he would be like you said
that he would like like he said that you
were trying to put on 20 pounds and he's
like never gonna happen your your uh
paper clip or whatever he said it not me
yeah okay yeah yeah code hanger sorry
yeah
anyway you go he if Barry Bonds is not
hitting zero home runs he's hitting a
lot of them it's still very good yeah
but if you go if if liver King is making
that's why it's a tricky it's a tricky
uh line to draw because you're like what
if liver Kings only making uh 40 Grand
is that okay yeah or like where is the
line that it's if he's on private jobs
another scenario because I was thinking
about this so um if you're a movie star
yeah okay so so let's take uh Chris
Hemsworth okay Thor uh Thor now
gun to your head no disrespect to him
yeah absolutely not okay so but good for
him
have you seen a lot of shirtless photos
of him both of y'all yes uh all day long
it's my screensaver but also in my mind
all the time I peeped it this morning
but I'm straight you're like I'm an
expert I am an expert on Chris Hemsworth
big handsome question yeah
what about uh the rock uh
not Navi no and not just trt there's a
lot of but they're not selling Fitness
however Prince Chris Helms Helmsworth
has a a uh workout routine that he sold
for 200 million dollars bro we covered
that the day we covered all that right
that's when there's getting to a point
so so there's there's there's there's
you're putting on muscle okay and you're
playing this character this Thor
character okay
there is
you're not talking about the fact that
you do this you're not getting it from
protein and just lifting weights you're
getting it from you know what's the
difference right yeah but but like if
we're going to start holding people
accountable to that stuff we have to be
a little bit careful right because a
little bit careful you've got a lot of
people who might be movie stars who are
gay and playing straight and if they
come out as gay their whole career is
over too yeah and I know we talked about
this but yeah it's a real dicey subject
because I'm talking to him it's a dicey
it's a dicey Thin Line it's a thin line
where do you draw the lineup where do
you draw the line that's awesome like
even with girls on Instagram who sell
products stuff like well you know maybe
your ass is fake teaser fake your lips
are fake she's has a filter but she
promotes this certain lifestyle in a
certain way
right are we going to get rid of them
like you think that's a natural get a
booster shot that's what he said yeah
yes and you endorse say his comment too
right it depends on I would I would say
it depends on what you're claiming the
supplements do yeah yeah if you're
claiming that what you're selling is
going to get you to look like this yeah
maybe that's where you draw the line if
you happen to be very muscular you take
a job you take steroids you also have
great genetics and you look great right
yeah maybe this guy Mike O'Hearn who
sells [ __ ] duck eggs or whatever it
is like if you're saying that these are
good for you and they're what I take
that comes out which is what the liver
King does he takes his own supplements
yeah I'm cool yeah it's when you start
saying that if you do these things you
can look like this now I don't know if
people don't like yeah I don't either I
don't think you've ever said that yeah I
don't think he said I don't think let me
ask you this that's all but but also
like when he came in here I didn't look
at him like oh my God this guy's Jack
did he take his shirt on yeah yeah he he
did his shirt I've never seen him with a
shirt yeah yeah he came in shirtless
out we have to power wash that chair it
smelled like this smell like hummus
really for days no no it's a good it's a
good man scent am I would I get like you
know like a um like uh a contact
if you saw to test you there he is
that's me trying the nuts he didn't
smell though he didn't smell he didn't I
know he just smells like natural yeah
and like look at Brian's like eye line
look at his gun
yeah yeah right down I was looking right
there but like I think on camera he
looks like super jacked but yeah when he
came in I was a smaller guy well you're
so big maybe you were looking down your
ankles no but but I didn't think he was
even that thick like you're looking at
it you're both looking at his body dude
whatever's going on with him where he
has to work out that hard twice a day is
that's an interesting thing so I there's
a there's an extreme there's an extreme
extremism in this person that's why
everyone follows him yeah he's extreme
he's in he's eating you know cow wieners
and balls it's like a like a lot of like
like country music guy there's from
Nashville they're saying about like you
know uh dirt roads and and you find out
like they're from Pasadena and you know
it no one has a problem with someone
being prepared or take my situation
because I like oh this is a guy a single
guy in his 30s that's just on the road
as a comic and like hooking up with
girls or whatever we're like yeah but he
said he said same with the liver King he
said he was Christian or yeah like if
you somebody's like I'm on
the leader of Jenny Craig or something
and you see in the McDonald's
drive-through you go wait yeah no you
said but but that's what people have a
problem with not the behavior that's a
liability with having a brand in general
they want you to be consistent across
the board and that's just yeah it was
being in the public eye feel me and we
don't have time if you don't want to I
don't but I'm just curious like with the
Christian thing but you can be Christian
still hook up with girls
um it's I described it as kind of like
you worked for a company when they said
you you can't wear jeans to the office
and I wore jeans to the office and Eric
you can't work here anymore like that's
that's the rules of because I was
working in church
yeah so people in church church aren't
allowed to date well it's the same
that's everybody that's why all of my
fans were trying to figure out because
they go what do what do we want he's a
single guy it's a it's so if that can he
date one girl yeah can he date what is
it so weird that's where he did the same
thing with the Liberty like where I
would suggest that that that that's had
nothing to do with anything other than
taking down somebody who's competent and
in the yeah then you don't like that you
know this is guys this guy's up here and
but the same with uh Andrew Tate or
whatever not to compare ourselves to him
in any way or they go oh everyone's here
he's up here now have you noticed the
have you noticed the media the
mainstream media needs a villain and now
that Trump is kind of out who's who are
they who are they for a while musk Elon
Musk oh yeah have you read this how they
call him of Tyran how what he's doing at
Twitter
yeah and then now that he's leaking the
Biden the hunter Biden have you seen the
hunter
um
and the New York Times still won't come
in a word we're getting New York Times
they're Phil
the majority of major networks because
they're saying they're in cahoots it's
like it's like how much more of your
credibility you want to lose just be
objective that's why everybody's
everybody everybody watches listens to
podcasts really I know because everybody
goes no I don't trust it I agree and
then but I just I just want to make like
a uh like I make a lot of sketches I
want to make like a uh alt left person
with the Tesla because now they're like
but they can't get they have a Tesla
because they thought he stood for yeah
something that he never did yeah well
listen now she's like I sold my test
hilarious yeah I bought a Volkswagen I
sold an American car that's water German
car comments were like you know who
created Volkswagen right Nazis it's all
[ __ ] the best thing about about I think
Kanye win a mask yeah wild Dude tell me
when I'm at not like uh but he's in a
like a mask I think he's a little crazy
yeah yeah what medicine are you taking I
turned you into a full-fledged Nazi what
antidepressants do you take I like
Hitler but but like the extremists when
he was on the uh that show with Jones
that the extremists like I agree with
his opinions but he has a mask like they
don't know how to feel it yeah yeah yeah
well yeah it is true that they they do
need
yeah I mean he's got gloves on it's
really weird
that's a tough look it's you think it's
there's something he's clearly clearly
completely manic like there's something
very wrong
UFC 282 is here kids and you want to
make some bank and you gotta do it my
friends at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
this Saturday it's a fun one new
customers can bet just five buckaroos
pre-fight money line on any fighter to
win and get 150 in free bets if they do
check this out right now everyone can
earn up to 50 boost when he plays the
same game parlay on UFC 282 these fights
are fantastic kids you got your main
event Jan blockovich versus Mega Man you
got Patty pimlet Jared Gordon Darren
till duplicies you have Bryce Mitchell
topiria you got it all going down if you
want to make money this way you should
do it you can't just bet on the favorite
one you gotta put up 100 to win 140 or
whatever the if it's a minus 140. you
gotta parlay these things and they boost
your parlay so let's say you're feeling
froggy and you want to really up your
Boost game you want to do a parlay like
all the favorites like Bryce Mitchell
duplicies Patty pimlet and magomed
you're gonna make more money all right
because the likelihood of all four of
them winning is not great but that's the
best way to make some Bank bro also the
John blockavage if you do want to bet
against the dog yawn who's the former
light heavyweight champion of the world
you might know him from beating uh Izzy
you might know him from beating a few
guys used to be the light heavyweight
champion of the world take the take the
prop bet on him winning uh via knockout
under two rounds that's a great bet odds
are great too all right so get you some
man
throw down on the parlay and download
the app use the promo code fighter bet
five dollars pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and get 150 in free bets
if they do that's code fighter this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official Sports brain part of the UFC
minimum age eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details come
watch a fight campaign watching UFC 282
that's this Saturday 7 P.M live on thick
boy YouTube topaz fight companion with
myself Brian Callan Sam tripley and
Frank Grillo baby come get you some the
boys will be having a good time tune in
Friday fight companion bar stool doing a
collab thick boy Barstool it's going
down rough and rowdy no I'm sorry
December 9th this Friday 5 p.m theovan
Don Cerrone Rampage Jackson and myself
we are going live at 5 p.m on thick boy
YouTube make sure you subscribe make
sure you tune in and make sure you buy
the pay-per-view Seasons beatings rough
and rowdy 19. Providence Rhode Island
see you there kids well I've seen in in
that case we told that we used to have a
buddy from our high school that we would
like in our group text we would he was
on Facebook and we were roasting him for
like look at him look it up and then
somebody found out he had like a mental
oh we go oh oh yeah yeah oh no no never
mind yeah never mind oh if you're like
doing this for attention then that's
like but if you're like no off you're
mad that's not funny to me Robert Supply
who wrote a book called behave and he's
a uh I don't know I'm sorry brain
scientist he said and I think this is
true he said we're gonna look back in 10
years 15 years 20 years whenever it is
and we're going to go God you remember
how we treated Kanye remember what
remember how we treated that because he
had that thing in his brain yeah that
that we didn't know about and we all we
had that [ __ ] thing that was making
him crazy he said we're gonna find
things it's like schizophrenics back
together back in the old days you run
them at the stage because they were
possessed by demons now of course we
know that's a it's a brain thing but the
more we learn from the brain we're going
to realize it's there are people that
have psychotic breaks and they are
straight up that's [ __ ] straight up
crazy well but uh but I think it's crazy
but I think the biggest thing is if you
know he's having one of these manic
episodes which I don't know if I
subscribed to that but because he's done
stuff before that shot well you do have
to be careful about making excuses right
you know what I'm saying because you
know if he was saying whatever rap sucks
or this rapper sucks that's fine yeah
and you're anti-semitic and you're
posting Nazi symbols and stuff that's
like okay but then it's dark okay
but then also but here's my thing if
he's having a manic episode right we
wouldn't have him on here yeah even
though we because we don't do anything
for views we wouldn't profit off of that
no no
platform you gotta take some
responsibility here you know he's going
to do this you know he's gonna say some
wild [ __ ] you probably shouldn't give
him a platform yeah just let him do his
thing on his social media but don't give
him a huge plan because you see the same
with like Antonio Brown Yeah from that
that he goes oh he's he's at the surface
he looks doing things for it and then
you go oh if he like has CTE I'm not uh
stand off I don't want that blood on my
hand again
like two few days ago he's yeah he's got
he's got brain damage there's something
but I mean what about the um what's the
guy that uh
um just took his took his life the uh
like boy band singer oh uh Carter yeah
that he would just he was a punchline on
the internet for years it was like the
Nickelback of Music the year yeah for
for years and that and that and that
that's how we talked him before this
podcast like we we'll like
roast other Comics like privately they
lost each other but you never hear me
publicly say another to to a fan or two
like another comic sucks me neither and
I never heard it and sometimes it's
warranted and I'll have people like dude
are you gonna hear from me no no no I
don't do that no it's not it's not what
I say it to his face I don't want to say
it yeah yeah but you said the the uh the
episode with when y'all were confusing
me with Carl Lentz which is funny but
you said you saw him yeah and you were
like hey and it was I was going to his
thing every Wednesday in Beverly Hills
yeah at the uh the church yeah the
church yeah oh that's right yeah and
then I made fun I was roasted did you
know him
I Know Carl yeah yeah really good she
seems like a nice guy yeah that's the
problem you go you meet him and because
I because we we had been friendly with
each other and then that came out and
you go and I've been on the other side
of it and I go
a it also doesn't do me any good to
defend someone publicly yeah so you
caught and he probably was like hey man
don't defend me yeah but I didn't want
anyone to defend me either I go hey but
I remember the people who trashed me
yeah for sure oh you remember that and
you also remember people had your back
though for sure that's when you know
yeah when you're at the bottom yeah
you're at the bottom when you [ __ ]
know yeah and nobody you go well I don't
where where do you just don't say
anything if you're not good when you go
through destruction and
people you remember you remember the
people that never
texted you and my it's so funny I'm such
a lawyer I don't mean I'm such a little
dog I know the people I think Colin
takes him I don't talk to them yeah yeah
I don't even do shows with them anymore
well clearly Brian's over he's over yeah
break down hives
I'm coming well people know I think like
now I of course there's you get like
you're like very extreme people are
doing extreme but I I would gather that
for the most part you find yourself
being sympathetic with people that are
getting crushed publicly yes same same
time same and I'm really sympathetic
someone who gets hate right I get a lot
of hate so with like Liberty I'm like
gay [ __ ] up but for you guys dog
piling I'm like yes sometimes things
people are pieces of [ __ ] and they
deserve it right like Harvey Weinstein
yeah
he's a criminal who's in jail
yeah versus a guy that like like the
liver King kind of like he like I bet
because I I've been to rehab and you go
to every day every two days maybe
there's a new person that checks in a
new person checks in and in essence
they're at the like that's a rock bottom
there was a guy that was a pastor at a
huge mega church you know 20 000 people
they found out about some stuff he's
cheating on his wife is they came to his
desk with a bag
and go
we know about everything if you check
into rehab we'll pay for it if you leave
right now get in this get in this car go
to the airport and this is life
in a in a five minutes and the next day
you're sitting in rehab with a bunch of
addicts and have nothing like that's
that
well I would just it was like I was just
so scared it was 2019 and I was drinking
a lot I did it uh yeah drinking
depression yeah uh workaholism
narcissism
your dad's a pastor so yeah judgmental
no pretty cool no everybody anyone that
everybody's flawed man yes and everybody
has everybody has a form of an
alcoholism everybody yeah like if you
start judging people for for if you've
ever had experience with alcohol real
alcoholics and I know you have yeah
um you know it's it's it's it's a
[ __ ] hard thing too you gotta look
you gotta you realize you have something
like that in yourself too yep and you're
just lucky you don't have a certain like
some sometimes people have an alcoholism
that's so beyond their control and if
it's booze yeah some people are uh
Workaholics whatever or some people have
like the attention from Instagram the
definition of addiction hits definition
of addiction is uh repeated attempts to
quit despite mounting consequences
that's my thing about phones so me and
Michael Thomas like I think in like 10
years yeah people are my God you you
remember when people just giving kids
iPads or with the social media was just
afraid they study the people the
engineers study something called
persuasion technology yeah at Stanford
University there is a there is a science
called persuasion technology those
clicks and all that like they call it a
race down the brainstem yeah they're
they're lizard brain yeah and you're
just you know and we all fall for it
well my thing is the most the most
disciplined people I know the people I
respect you know I have a good work
ethic people that Trump me yeah I see
how addicted they are to their phones
I'm like this is such a problem it's not
good yeah but you go get you go like
there was a guy in rehab that was a
professional baseball player in the
major leagues and he was addicted to
video games he was addicted to it and he
would every so that you know baseball
they got like three four game Road Trip
he would go every you go never never
playing video it's like everyone buys a
carton of cigarettes they buy a pack
because they're like I'm not yeah I'm
not doing that yeah and I've had Comics
that come out on the road with me that
buy a pack I could stop and get a pack I
was like dude just buy a carton so we
don't have to keep stopping something
you're gonna but he goes every every
road trip four or five game Road Trip
get there first day would go Uber to
Walmart buy an Xbox and a television and
the games damn and play and then now
just leaving the hotel and never left
the hotel never practiced never did
anything and then you would leave it
there because he goes I'm never doing it
again and every road trip he would do
that I'm never playing these games again
but that's how addiction is yes because
you go you can't I'm never going to stop
on your own no no yes you need to have
it people get that away with my comedy
and I want to thank people
but you when you check the rap you're an
addicted to like no no no I mean I've
been obviously just depressed yeah
addictive personality
I mean I'm sober I've been sober since
that day well sex is a pretty when it's
available yeah yeah yeah yeah but it but
it go if you go like I was I was very I
was looking for something because I was
you understand I was a Christian I still
am a Christian but I was I was publicly
like everyone started to be like I was
making poor choices in my personal life
since day one but now everyone knew me
as like a Christian
and I go oh this is this is the Kamikaze
Mission yeah yeah because like you're
like liver King this is got out of
control this one if I get if I continue
to get I took these four deals it's a
comic comedy and I told my agents and
managers that I go this is the comic
comic Kamikaze Mission they're like shut
up get out there make money yeah but I
was also like I go one more tour deal
one more promoter deal yeah because I
was like I'm gonna I gotta yeah
ten points you know what Kamikaze means
what anyone yeah of course Japanese
would commit suicide by crash no no
what's the definition
no there's a definition of it there this
is you mean what's the English it's the
translation we say Kamikaze what's
amazing translation it means divine wind
were the were the kamikaze pilots were
they were they volunteers or were they
forced to do it forced they were they
were volunteers oh really yes and were
they primary what are we talking about
Pearl Harbor what this isn't World War
II okay yeah and so uh volunteers huh
yep and and were they were they
um they are they were they college
educated primarily or were they not
college educated they thought of someone
I've never thought about I know it's
already interesting they were yeah they
were they study for the most part Math
Science and Engineering or did they
study poetry second engineering
engineering they studied they were they
were artists they studied art poetry
literature it's just like romantic
exactly and they would write they would
always write a Haiku poem to their
family
um before they went there was a whole
ritual [ __ ] whole rich man not to get
darker you guys but I was getting this
guy who he was a principal and uh he got
a altercation with his wife she had uh
two daughters he was like their father
but they weren't his blood kids
he had a altercation yelling match she
calls a cop saying he's hitting me he's
never hit anybody in his life he's been
a principal for like 30 years he goes to
jail
um then it comes out you know he hit his
wife blah blah she's like oh my god look
we were talking about once the
toothpaste comes out there's no going
back when you can't somebody like oh I
didn't know he's gonna be homeless yeah
same thing with this guy she calls says
gets the cops there said he's hit me he
didn't touch her she didn't realize how
bad it was going to get for him he lost
his job he's gonna leave yeah so she's
calling like I made that up I I was just
out of control just trying to hurt him
the worst I could he didn't lay a hand
on me he never has he's the most gentle
guy in the world he loses his job
everything this dude goes on Facebook
right the suicide note kills himself
[ __ ]
people who commit suicide no they'd see
they see no way out the cloud they don't
the clouds blocking the Sun and they
they believe in their hearts that the
clouds never gonna go away yeah but to
do that okay you'd have to have a
profession right like you in the moment
that's called hopelessness and despair
yeah so because what happens is all you
have is your reputation yeah all you
have is your your career now you can't
provide for your family yeah you've been
in jail the future everything you had
all the plans you had for the future
especially your reputation everything is
shattered yeah and now you have nothing
yeah and and you don't see a way out one
of the things about chaos yep I've been
there same is that you're in the middle
of a rowboat and and you don't have a
paddle and there the sea is Raging and
there's no land in sight and you have no
idea how to get back and the only thing
you can do is go the only thing I held
on to as I go all right look I I know I
know I'm a good person I know I'm
innocent let me see now who the [ __ ] I
really am if I'm gonna die yeah I'm
gonna die like they're gonna count I'm
taking me down he's Gonna Roll the boat
with you I gotta take me down like this
come on baby come on come on I had a big
ass or okay yeah yeah [ __ ] my crap you
go in in the uh too and we just went in
circles so I only brought one row which
is like this
talk about that guy that was uh off the
cruise ship
last week this week he there was an
article that came out and goes he made
up his mind he was absolutely determined
to live God and you but that makes sense
because if you go Oh no you're it's done
yeah you're done yeah 15 now you go
there must have been you go 15 hours
they said he was kicking off sharks
absolutely yeah
yeah I promised he was like I was so
scared because the Sharks were starting
to swarm come on yeah
stories because when you go Jesus when I
when I so like there were nurse sharks
but there so everybody when I was in
rehab they're every like just stacks of
mail every day just I don't even know
how they found out where I was stat in
everybody's letter was the same
everybody's letter goes hey when I was
25 I got a DUI and got fired yeah hey
when I was 30 I worked this so
uh uh like encouragement oh God because
everybody had been to the bottom
and now like when I was in rehab and Sam
Hunt which is a buddy of is a country
singer Craig's country
got a DUI and I go we got to talk to we
got to find him we gotta find him and we
gotta tell him to stay on Earth yeah
just stay just because it's it's that
when I was at the bottom everybody knew
they go I know what that feeling is and
I'm and I'm also 15 years or 10 years or
three years I mean it's better they and
they go I'm compelled to find where this
guy is on this planet and there was like
my sister was like getting notes from
friends that were like co-workers they
were like if it made me cry they go if
you know John
help find him yeah and tell him yeah and
that saved my whole life yeah and now
all I want to do is you because you were
helping somebody else yes and that
that's what's amazing here's here's the
other thing that they have found forget
religion even but like and I appreciate
that story because psychologically
you're way happier when you stop
thinking about yourself oh way happy the
other thing I learned is that I swear to
God man it rewired my brain because I
just got I stopped worrying about myself
a lot of times yeah I was like I was
like I said to my father one time I I
really meant that I go I'm not afraid to
die me neither and he said he got really
nervous I go I'm not saying I'm suicidal
they know this about me I'm not afraid
to [ __ ] die I used to be afraid I'm
still afraid okay I'm not you know but
you know what I'm saying it's like you
get you get the braver but but what
really helped me too was listening to
Jordan Peterson's uh lectures on the
Bible yeah and about how any time you
are cast into the desert you gotta still
will have faith and when you don't have
faith that's what it is so the metaphors
in the Bible the metaphors for anybody
and anybody who I've admired has come up
against themselves and face our
connection I don't think anybody
survived I don't think anybody escapes
if you're alive long enough and if
you're really trying for something I
don't think anybody escapes the the
chaos the flood and loss I also don't
respect those people like what's America
love more than anything comebacks yeah
or somebody that overcame something
about every movie but every movie
exactly it's the the hero's journey the
hero's journey is you fight up you fight
the monster you're gonna fight in every
movie you don't have any Weaponry for
like it's so overwhelming we all go away
he's about to fight a dragon there's no
holy [ __ ] well it's also comparison UFC
like I won't co-sign a guy till I see
him lose around it's not going his way
yeah when they're just dominating him I
can't do it yet we don't know it was
Anthony Joshua until he fought Vladimir
Klitschko I was like I'm not willing to
say he's the greatest right now I'm not
can't and then he gets knocked down like
let's see what he does fires back like
well now I can vouch for that there you
go and everybody
tell me out about you're starting okay
your situation is I'll get emotional is
I thought we were all gonna fight man I
thought we were what happened yeah I
thought we were all gonna fight right
where did you guys go right you left
though we were in a community no we
weren't free yeah you guys were friends
because we could help you yeah and then
when we need your help out the most you
guys are nowhere to be found even to
this [ __ ] day
[ __ ] you but you gotta forgive
sure people are afraid and they don't
know I don't know
I don't hold resemble I don't even think
about it to be honest with you but also
[ __ ] you yeah that was that white board
out there is that people that you hate
there was yeah it's a whole list okay so
you don't you don't just published
okay yeah write it down I feel better
who's the guy with the like why is it
really matters and he's got like why are
some X style I'm like well and he's got
one of those Bob things where he's just
twisting his head yeah
well it's true it doesn't do it doesn't
like did your dad say when you're going
through all this dude it was his good
dad I said yes aren't you like one of
like one of eight yeah first guy one of
eight first guy there dude yeah come on
anybody that like in when you go into
the
the wildest Story I mean the people
coming to rehab that have killed people
like if like unbelievable consequence of
actions but
you hear the story from childhood to
there and again we I don't think anyone
on this podcast has ever defended
anyone's Behavior or let anyone off the
hook for wrongdoing no but they you hear
the story from birth to what they did
and you go I get it yes that's it I get
it and if you have it feels told me he's
like yeah it comes hey hey meetings with
me he's like hey you get material I bet
we've been we've been yeah and things
like B the stories man you have he's
like you're a compassion dude but you
meet these guys so you'd love this I
would be giving out money
I'm in Naples I'm in Naples and I'm ho
homing it just having a tough one I was
just having Staples
why is exactly right but yeah I'm
complaining about some [ __ ] I was a
little down about something but not
something
yeah I know I actually sold well this
weekend but like it was sold out but
like they weren't laughing like you know
yeah I was just I didn't get a standing
ovation I went back in my role index and
I got I got mad my I I let the demons
come in yeah I know but I was like you
know long time coming Daddy yes my
wife's there with my baby and
everything's good and it's Naples and
the weather's great yeah and I [ __ ]
you with our boy eating good food yes
you let him out I call my boys got
cancer okay and uh his mom answers the
phone so I'm down I call my boy he's got
cancer his mom answers she's crying and
he's dying and I say how you doing he
goes I'm struggling you know but I'm I'm
doing the best I can because we would
talk all the time okay cool listen I'm
in Naples because we went through this
he got cancer and I went through these
things we would talk all the time you
know he's and so I said I know this
don't uh Cameron Booth one of the best
guys because I met him he was the guy
who's my dad's caddy oh yeah yeah and
part of the family he was part of the
family because we got so close to him
and he's just a beautiful human being
and a halibut that that's not him he's
30 he was 38 years old 38 years old
beautiful beautiful guy but anyway so
long story short he died three hours
later oh no and and uh and so so here I
am so my I'm talking to everybody who's
clearly in Crazy pain yeah right yeah
and then I look over I look over and
there's a woman she's in a wheelchair
her husband's this Burly guy with three
kids and he's doing everything she's
never gonna walk again he's got her and
he's got the three kids and he's got a
smile on his face and so does she and I
looked at my wife I go what was I
[ __ ] done what was I complaining
about what [ __ ] what what bitching was
I doing yeah
it's all perspective right it's like
your world like that that's why a is
good because you go there and you have
these oh right yeah I would go all my
shows there was like you know the
lighting's not right the sound guy
didn't do this and I was when I was in
Rio when I was in the I was like if I
could ever do stand-up again for two
people I'm not nice I go
I've never you're gonna ever hear a word
from me and everybody that works with me
prior employees were like this guy was a
dick dude talking about me yeah it's not
I just very just
I mean I always say like dude I look the
devil in the eye I looked him in the eye
yes and and I go anybody that didn't
y'all should have killed me when I was
down there yeah because now I really do
feel like that yeah yeah yeah and now
I'm getting straight now but aren't you
aren't you a fundamentally different
person sometimes you're a different
person I'm 100 fundamentally different
100 anyways I can just my my Outlook in
life because when you're young or when
when things are worked out you you
believe that the laws of the universe
like you're just there's an arrogance
yeah anybody in life who hasn't had to
come up against themselves I'd look it
in the eye and hasn't lost everything
like and when you lose you when you hold
like let's say it's uh your cars or your
career or your relationships or your
whatever and every all of that's all you
have it all gets taken yeah
all of it and then you go
oh
and it takes a while it's not overnight
but you go oh I'm now because I was so
scared on no I'll tell you you were
walking around just like everybody else
like this you when you're when you walk
around and in your mind you won't admit
it in your mind you actually believe
you're one of God's page yeah yeah 100
you wanted God's favorite yeah and then
all then the flood hits and you go you
go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no God doesn't
have any favors here oh yeah I think for
you and Chris going through it like you
guys are both you guys are both matured
yes
now you're acting your age which bums me
out well that's a bummer though yeah
well but I think you go through
something like that like you just yeah
you want to you want to keep your
silliness stuff you want to keep your
silliness you want to be a silly goose
but also what do we tell you like when
you came back to find a kid like you
call me like man it's just not where
he's doing it's all good dude we just
got a different person chin You're Gonna
Come chin too I love that guy
we got but it's also like like we talked
about like I was like don't worry the
Celia should come back well you you're a
tough guy man yeah you know Brendan's a
tough [ __ ] dude like I'm not just
physically but like you're a very tough
guy like you you have the ability to
I mean I don't know you know to take it
to take to if you if you're watching it
from the outside which I like I know
like we know of each other's comments
that we like to watch
the ego
God yeah that guy's getting it really
and you and you go uh you have to kill
him you've got to be you gotta kill you
better put a bullet in his head he's
never going away
haters like kill yeah okay cool yeah
yeah good luck but it really you realize
after all that stuff is like is like oh
the the people on Twitter are like they
got a gun to your head and then you
realize they're shooting blanks yeah
like a live stream playing they're
shooting those things boom there you go
it's just yeah like like a confetti and
you go oh monkeys in the trees but I was
yeah but those those whenever I remember
the first time somebody said something
critical of me right when I was starting
to kind of rot and it dude it took me it
came up fast though very fast like in a
year yeah yeah and I was selling you
know Arenas and there was like you said
I like him at first he destroyed yeah
like a year yeah but then you go but I
it was so scary because I was like this
whole house of cards here is gonna be
because this is all I have and then you
go
oh dude I mean I I'll get be criticized
for being here
honest did you become worse of course
yeah of course did you get more did you
get more religious uh I would say way
more of a Christian now than it was
before yeah way more how so well I I
guess you know I guess when even I
shouldn't asked that question because I
don't I don't really know Christianity
like I couldn't know I didn't know you
couldn't DM girls and like date well but
think every religion has restrictions
right yeah but I think what the religion
I think what religion should do whether
you're Christian or whatever is and this
is what I really really try to live now
is truth like it you can't [ __ ] lie
to yourself yeah to the people closest
to you because you will pay a price
coming for you and and so that leads me
like I do believe in truth and I do
believe in truth with a capital T now
that's that's telling the truth yeah you
understand like that that to me is like
again it's like you will never get away
with anything you know it's crazy
you know your eyelid surgeries finally
paying off somebody said that too
somebody said oh the island sir I've
heard some people get that was a
nightmare yeah it really paid off you
have bags in your eyes the tops down
here up here both yeah both I didn't
know he did this you know they did do
you know that oh I know they did I
didn't know that that's why your eyes
were so funny I thought they were only
taking the skin here they took skin from
down here too yeah which I didn't know
didn't touch and I said I said to him I
go I go um
Jason I go did you take how much do you
take off just a little bit he goes kind
of a lot I was like oh it's finally paid
off yeah I'm a good looking guy
good looking guy but uh go back to you
so how did you get more uh Christian
well because like like
if I if you go to any if it go if you
there are obviously the news is full of
Christian and Catholics and not the
single Diamond but doing horrific things
horrific but like Catholic Church 80
I've read like 80 of the the uh
philanthropic uh donations in this
country or from Christians if you if you
were in a city and lost go to a church
yes again there's humans in them so it's
not but they will help you yeah and they
they will give you they will try their
best these people live a great
atrocities has been committed in the
name of religion it doesn't mean it's
all bad though no and and to to like for
me to go like
you you go through this experience and
then you could either go I could easily
and you could both of y'all could go alt
left or alt right could go atheist or
double down in Christianity yeah you
could go to either extreme oh I'm
anti-cancel culture alt-right guy or
screw religion um like but
be smarter like some of it's good some
of it's better but to carry this
I'm gonna think for myself and the
Christian Christians
kept me on Earth Christian people kept
me on that and your family still
majority 100 Christians people are
flawed all of them it also has something
called redemption and forgiveness yeah
and redemption and forgiveness is a very
powerful thing it's what I said about
your enemies the most radical thing
about Jesus Christ the most radical
things love your enemy yeah turn the
other cheek that's a radical concept but
he didn't have social media I know not
just sell all your not just sell all
your goods and give the money to the
poor but if that is if you believe in
the Bible or not if that is a true story
that he was hanging on the cross and he
said forgive them for they not they
don't know what they're doing yes
and you think it's a true story I do
that is an unbelievable that is an
unbelievable and I have I I I want to
yeah Crush people that tweet at me I
want to kill them but but I just think
it's interesting that we're still
talking about that yeah 2500 years later
think about the best example yeah it but
it still Bears relevance so so so see
going to a comedy store tonight every
Comics they have a joke about Jesus
every one of them I'm sure every one of
them I'm sure I'm sure still relevant
always the most famous because you lay
your head on the pillow at night yeah
and you go and sell in Jersey about that
but but the Bible the Bible has been
relevant for so long you have to you yes
there are contradictions and flaws sure
it just I'm not a Christian but just
it's got something to offer yeah yeah
it stood the same thing yeah you know
well my my grandma's super religious
don't judge me because I wouldn't go to
church as much as she would like yeah
and uh when she was about to pass away
she was so excited yeah yeah like crunk
yeah she was getting into the hottest
club in Miami and she couldn't wait to
get in yeah I was like oh I'm so jealous
of that well it is if there's a church
we could drove up here from Irvine we
passed 5 000 churches for sure it must
be
look at his bad comparison buddy like
you look at cocaine you're like
it must be doing something for you well
humans it's all human beings they say
they say I've heard this all human
beings are religious all of them yeah
now you might be religious about science
you might be religious about the you
might pray to the god of Russia you got
to worship something you might be you
might get worse you've got to be atheism
yeah but at the end of the day my party
to the god of yourself you but that's
that's the biggest thing people yeah
yeah the number one lesson in the old
and certainly in the in the King James
Bible is that what were the Israelites
constantly constantly punished for by
God worshiping false Idols when they
said we want a king he goes you want a
king I'm the king I all you need is the
Commandments you're fine they're like no
we want a king and he said okay if
that's what you want it's it was one
thing so worship of man worship of of
money worship of status worship power
worship of anything was always always in
in at least the abrahamic religions
which is Judaism Christianity and Islam
always considered see I I think religion
should almost be like picking your uh
College uh major because I want to get
more educated on it go through it and
then decide oh sorry it's too late for
him he's you're going to help yeah yeah
sorry we should have said that up top
hey bro yeah sorry sorry sorry
yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry yeah that was
confusing we gave him hope a little bit
yeah yeah sorry sorry you pillared right
now with some holy ghost power I don't
want him you pillowed with some holy
ghost power I don't want it on your ship
I started a cult no but you pillars holy
ghost power I started cult huh I'll tell
you what I'm gonna do when I get up to
heaven late anybody no see when I go to
heaven though because I love you I'm
gonna say a little prayer and a good
word for me put a little good word I'm
gonna go hey I'm gonna go Holy Father
Can you make it not as hot for him is it
are you going to be up there first
before him at the end of the day I got a
full heart and clear clear eyes oh yeah
well I'm bigger I'm like a Great Dane
you're more of like a chihuahua thing
yeah oh yeah what's the best example oh
my dog comes today
everybody everybody kind of like
I'll send you a picture that's a good
looking dog yes yeah that one looks like
he's got dogs Panther I don't have any
dogs no no no dogs no kids oh nothing
well you're still young he's my age 38.
dude we're Pisces Bros are we March 20th
I've never pounded somebody for that but
dude take it first time well what do you
think everybody gravitates toward like
it like a like
it's uncomfortable to be worshiped when
somebody's like I'm a super fan you're
like oh that's awkward but but I want
like I've met guys that like that have
impacted me in a certain way authors
musicians even athletes that I did I
enjoy I love watching because he's like
oh it's like it's like I'm uncomfortable
but a man is naturally made to worship
yes to yes go even yes Chris Martin from
Coldplay I was like dude I've been in
some dark dark places and his music oh
interesting might be stolen from but I
go dude you you
have saved me not I mean did you say
that to him no but you want to yeah but
it would be like okay it'd be like but
so would y'all ring scene was that way
for me I mean honestly but it's like I
was lost and I didn't want it he kind of
I don't know brought me closer to what
all his songs it just brought me closer
there's my dog dude
he's 11 weeks older damn you know and I
told the guy go I'll pay you extra if
you don't clip his ears he goes we only
clip ears and Tails yeah because the
show dog I like it I like the clips
there's no people get mad but I like
that look there's no grip from you yeah
I like that yeah he's had a security
my kids don't know my girl doesn't know
my girl does not want a dog so you're
just gonna show up he's showing up at
five o'clock I'm gonna say hey man this
is what we're doing okay tonight tonight
but the Breeders
don't you would say this like showing
that
for another human giving that dog like
someone on Twitter saying oh it seems so
yeah what yeah like like the best part
of my entire weekend is my little nephew
who lives out here uh he is a a Rams fan
and I go what does he want for Christmas
his mom said he wants a whole he loves
the Rams and like Jersey Jersey pants
shoulder pads wristbands gloves helmet
what Jersey did you get them
yeah yeah he's
three four be funny if you're like he's
25 yeah it's weird yeah yeah yeah he's
32 years old but to give that was the
best part about to give oh like nothing
and I couldn't wait I can't wait to give
it to provide that guy with butterflies
I can't wait to do another you should my
son he's not gonna go to Jitsu he's like
why Dad I'm like you'll see and that's
the same when you were loses
but wouldn't you say that you you you
called your friend with cancer because
because when you've been to the bottom
you know that's the way out dude you
know that stuff you called you know a
lot of people didn't call him yeah
really yes a lot of people nobody wants
to be around nobody it's very natural
depressing it happens yeah it's true
this is very sad but it's very natural
when it happens when you're getting very
old what happens when you're dying is
that people stop calling because you
remind them of their their mortality and
I make made sure I always called that
[ __ ] I think that's even with
like cancer culture like a comic who's
not selling where their podcast isn't
hot like you won't get as many calls
yeah
how did you how do you feel with your
conscience wise that you use that cancer
story as you're closer that night is
that you know what and uh yes I mean I
mean because I turned I turned up I turn
a negative
yeah he would let you say you're you're
honoring him negative into a posse
that's what I do all right I said that
to him well my buddy was dying and I he
and I I [ __ ] said he was a comic Sam
Brown and I go I left him a message I
wrote him I go dude listen um because he
was dying and so I his wife was going to
read him the note and I don't think she
ever got to I think unfortunately but I
I don't know and I go uh I love you man
I'm thinking about you and uh not to be
a dick but you're not using a material
and it's so [ __ ] good
she was like you're such a sick [ __ ] I
go he'll love this it's a lot though
when you got because that when my
uncle's my you know North Star when he
was passing away my Aunt Sophie touched
was like hey write your uncle an email
he's gonna go any like in the next yeah
yeah if you hear write an email and I'm
gonna read it to him right now that's so
cool yeah so I wrote him this long email
and tiger wasn't born I was like my
son's middle name's give me yours you
can take your packs yeah so you're right
the whole you know the email they went
to launch you know how long he has so
he's trying to give the cliff notes I
was trying to do tighten up that bit a
little bit yeah
and I said I said love you hopefully
I'll see you up there and then I put
sorry for the grammatical ears you know
I struggle with this stuff tell my dad
uh he's blaming on him he sent me to
public school she was like get this
stuff
yeah that's it laughter's [ __ ] it
well I I tell a story of my show my
There's a comic named Mark Lowry who's
an older Comics Christian comic he said
the best joke you ever told he's in the
hospital when his they're very religious
he was in the hospital his mom died him
his dad were both there right before she
died [ __ ] you know you have like a kind
of a Moment of clarity before death like
a little bit of uh uh and she goes I
think I see lights and she passed away a
true story I think I see lights that's
what him and his dad there he is
him and his dad were driving home from
the hospital no one has had a word and
his dad goes I can't believe mom said I
I think I see lights and he looked at
his dad goes you think it was Flames
look just that's an unbelievable
great job great job
because it's so like this like what
people I mean I got canceled it was like
one of my buddies we were in rehab and
he had he cheated on his wife and burned
his whole life to the ground lost his
job and everything and we were crying
together and every night and it was
horrible and I was starting to feel
better after like three weeks I was
starting to feel like oh maybe I can you
know starting to feel optimistic and
light came back to my face and and he
put his arm around me one day he goes
hey dude it looks like you're doing
really well in here but I just want to
let you know don't take suicide off the
table just yet
we're not out of the state yeah and I go
yeah
I understand how therapeutic that was
that's all I would do like I just like
will sassa was the best at that yeah
yeah yeah Will's dad had throat cancer
and he loved his fathers that was
amazing and uh and he had a very special
bond with him and yeah and I said you
know uh I'm sorry man he goes no it's
okay he's a steel horse he's stubborn
you know he's just a man he's just but
you know getting help and stuff and I go
all right buddy and we had to talk and I
love him you know and right before I go
I go and hey
don't I don't want you to get this in
your head either because like don't
think that if you had been more
successful as an actor maybe and if you
were working more that the stress
wouldn't have caused that you know so
I'm sure it had nothing to do with that
he's dying dude of course he's like but
wait why would you say that no I'm
saying not to think that that's all yeah
he would always like we would go to
these like AAA meetings and there was
like you know the rafters up there and
here we go hey dude like to hang myself
like he would always bad spot he would
always like grab he goes
as I'm leaving my father goes stay close
to the people that are uh that love you
I go yeah I will and he goes I got to
change my last name that's awkward
yeah and I suppose I go I go I can't get
any worse than this you guys yeah you
can yes it can it can yes it can yeah
you ever heard of a brain tumor yeah
they just drove off I'm like all right
there's even wiggle room at Rock Bottom
dude even Rock Bottom has wiggler I was
with my dad when his best friend when
his best friend died at the funeral the
guys this guy's making this speech yeah
about the guys up there going all I see
is nothingness now yeah because you have
left us and my father my father goes are
you kidding me with this guy yeah this
is what we're gonna do this this guy I'm
so depressed listening
to [ __ ] told jokes I think it is
roasted he roasted his friend so John
tell me so as a Christian comment how
does it work so with your material I
assume no cussing right yeah I mean not
yeah but even coming up like The Comedy
Works and some of the other venues you
wouldn't touch I never I wouldn't well I
just started like I don't blame anybody
like I just like my I said I called my
brother a butt head one time when I was
little and my mom washed my mouth out
with soap literal real that's like a in
a Christian like coming up in the 90s
that's what they that's how discipline
worked so I was just like I first went
to a comedy club to like because I
thought I wanted to do it I went to open
mic night and I heard guys
publicly
swearing and I was like
like this is insane like is it is the
manager not here or like I was like I'm
gonna get some soap I was just shocked
that they were doing it but not not
because that's just how I was raised
yeah so I'm just like and when I moved
out here to like become a comic and I
was like trying to get rid of everything
Christian in my show
and like kind of just be like a and then
I started like doing these Chris and
they were like dude we need like we need
every comic being them yeah like yeah we
don't do a version I was like I grew up
in church dude I grew up homeschooled
from the south the conservative my dad
is a pastor like they go just how often
would you go to church growing up three
times a week really yeah and then
homeschooled by yeah my mama so you know
the Bible inside all of it yeah yeah
yeah Old Testament New Testament yeah so
they go what I was trying to get rid of
all that stuff to become and then I
started making these videos they were
like so Niche like but Christians were
like
oh my God that's the funniest thing I've
ever heard because I was doing like and
like if you if you asked me to write a
joke about like
MMA yeah I wouldn't I don't know it
that's not your thing so then it'll be
like they'd be like you you got to do
that job yeah you got to do that job
you're making a joke about like being a
good looking guy on the road get a lot
of attention from women like you that's
it's yours yeah you gotta do you gotta
do that oh you're pointing that man yeah
yeah hey man no yeah no it looks like
somebody that's like hey beautiful eyes
maybe I have great eyes yeah you got to
do that yeah man I have my eyes are
young I can't do that like like because
like a 30 year old it's not yeah it's
not so now I lean into like this okay
but I'm like kind of like it's like kind
of comical I guess because they were
like oh this is like the like the I'm
like the bad boy of like Christianity
because I like roast it
but like in any comment I'm like the
cleanest most family friendly but in
amongst Christians like oh yeah
oh he made the fun of Joel Osteen or
whatever they're like oh he's a Phenom
he's wild dude also also a friend though
so you're not gonna catch me like a good
guy okay um but he seems like a nice I
can't think of anything bad about the
guys he was like well that's the thing
he's so magnetic I did a joke I did a
joke about him one time in down in
Houston and somebody his daughter-in-law
came into the green room after the show
and you're like it you'll love this he
goes dude if my dad and heard you tell
that joke he'd be dying laughing so he's
I bet he cool he's cool you know what
I'm saying like the people are like 59.
nobody looks better than nothing ah come
on come on nobody looks good I'm better
than that guy yeah I mean if you've seen
the crowds he pulls in oh my God and
that's religious I'll watch him I can't
believe he's that old about religion
about what's tricky about religion is
some of these like some of these like
those famous pastors like the car Lance
Joel like all these guys are so so
wildly charismatic and also you combine
that with religion it's you'll do
anything for them but these guys if this
guy was like a CEO of a business he'd be
oh they'd be successful wildly wildly
wildly successful and you combine that
with like this is what God told me yeah
it's just like you got to be very
careful with that I mean he's so he's so
positive who was the older one with the
Crazy Eyes remember that ladies like but
you're flying private chat you would
know who the the sky here
what's his name uh Kenneth Copeland
Kenneth Copeland surgery but bad lip
surgery same doctor as you buddy no no
different that he was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah this dude come on crazy there
it is yeah that guy right that guy yes
yes
but you like you said like if you're
gonna be like the private jet one was
hilarious
yeah that one that way yeah yeah that's
it tough yeah don't take that interview
I'm just gonna say I don't think that
they caught him off guard yeah they
surprised attacked him God damn those
eyes are scary
does Xena get that surgery you got
what he's got to get my doctor yeah no
that's what he does no he got he got he
went too crazy with it yeah because what
they do with that is they lift your
brows yeah
yeah he he was going viral for the wrong
reasons yeah that's not good yeah don't
take that interview yeah don't take that
every day they jumped on him though but
if you use like with all these type of
things like again religion in in and
sports franchises and anyone has the
kind of leader like if you were kind of
like
like if you're like I'm gonna buy this
prayer cloth from this guy and he's
going to cure me of cancer like get a
booster shot yeah like kind of like
again again I think he's going to be
able to help as a as a religious person
you're gonna be held accountable for
that I believe in in eternity yes but
like if you go to that and
get a booster shot I'm with you yeah
yeah like and then oh but going back to
the Christian Comics is it how many like
big Christian Comics are there doing
like who's the biggest I mean what is
beside you there's a lot of people that
are Christian well do comedy yeah but
not Christian and also do that brand
like that brand yeah there's like a lot
of guys like obviously who's napargatzi
is a Christian but he's not yeah he's
he's just a comic yeah I Christian even
Theo was supposed to say he's a great
like these are yeah
well a lot of people are believers in
Christ no I'm with you I'm like I'm
talking about guys like doing the things
uh there's obviously there's a guy named
Tim Hawkins is the uh he's the big he's
the he's the biggest the biggest is he
older yeah he's a little older than me
but he's he'll he'll sell and he's he'll
sell 5 000 seats in any city in America
okay
because there is a Christian Revival
correct me if I'm wrong among young
people including in cities like New York
City yeah yeah well Christianity is now
cool now yeah it kind of came why is
that yeah uh well it's worried about
technology that's not him that's a fake
photo of him but yeah yeah which one
killer no all of them yeah yeah
there's a call that he'll do the joke
about like click on that hand raising
top left in the in the Plaid one more
yeah this one here yeah can you can we
listen or no is that allowed we can
listen you can't show it okay all right
yeah yeah let me just get the idea of
what the joke is yeah
that's it yeah yeah just like that's a
great so it's so weird you said because
I could Crusher My Buddy goes come to
this church yeah I go alone and and
they're doing that they're doing this
what's the nomination first of all
there's a there's a band that plays in
the beginning yeah I'm already like you
know I'm just I'm I'm you know it's yeah
you don't know what to do with your
first thing but everyone else around
he's doing it it's in Pockets yeah all
right I'm just gonna and plus you got
this Christian band they're very good
but it's also like you know Chris
Church's supposed to be a little boring
what are you doing yeah no but I think
that's why there's well it's supposed to
be a little bit I thought there's more
people sign up we gotta go yeah
all right
okay no but what did you end up doing I
I I didn't do it yeah I was like I could
turn I should have put the lyrics up so
everyone can see them because I'm new I
don't know yeah but but that is similar
to every every subculture whether it's
uh black comic gay Comics Southern uh
Larry the Cable Guy if this is this guy
knows your life yeah the life that you
live yes like we have people like people
from flu from Hawaii to come to my show
last night they go we we're cool because
because you speak to yeah the people
they don't feel as alone no and after I
go dude if you think that my comedy is
is what I what is too much for you and
you're too religious that yeah hey we
can shake hands and yeah go separate
ways but if you if you
that's my Miranda comedy is a little
different than Tim's but if like you if
this is for you you're like that's my
guy yeah that is my that's all it is in
anything but that's everybody yeah
everyone has to do it they're an
intelligent guy you just see it I mean
your success is not a [ __ ] accident
well it's not just your eyes keep that
between us you know yeah and your height
yeah the internet and the timber of your
voice yeah I wonder what anything we
could collab on what are us three gonna
do we can't tour together can we all
right listen you're who's going to be in
the crowd of us three I might convert
you never know yeah Brian's leaning that
way he should figure out something it'll
be like people can watch me what is it
yeah well I talked to I talked to uh I
was on birds podcast yeah and we talked
a little bit about this and he was kind
of the same about like he's like
there's got to be some something else
out there oh yeah because that's what's
what's crazy about getting having money
is if you like I've always said like if
you buy a lottery ticket on Monday and
the drawing is on Sunday it's a billion
dollars you're not gonna win it but what
if you bought six days of Hope
your life is trash but for 10 bucks you
can go
there you go maybe maybe and that's
something and that's that's but that's
what everybody out here by the way
everybody out in these is is that's what
they hope in if they're not religious
they're hoping in a better tomorrow so
when the rent control or when you're
politician or when the taxes it I hope
tomorrow
but then we all have we all I mean you
were Rich he's not but like like we have
it
I'm just joking with it like we I know
you I know you have to leave but there's
no I my thing is different like my my
interest in faith is
in the doing of it and it's like it's
almost like
I
somehow find or get a lot out of
believing
that I can
ask to be the best version of myself
like yeah so so so I think that we have
Sinners and Saints and everything in
between in our bodies right yeah
absolutely so you got hell in yourself
you got heaven but I I wanna
I wanna like I I think with if you ask
for it you can become
the version of yourself you never even
thought was Within Reach that's what
that's what it is
converting late yeah there's no hope for
me I never said I was converting it
might be yeah we said there's no hope
for we might switch that yeah it might
be yes Holy Ghost yeah I'll talk to you
he's [ __ ] doing tobacco he's yeah
I'll talk to I'll talk to Joe he has a
preacher hair preachers seem to have
very good hair awesome great hair great
hair top tier top tier yeah I mean I
think you go so you I mean you got some
tour dates coming up Daddy Long Beach
Florida tickets still left for that
Irvine sold out months in advance Miami
Florida improv that thing's sold out
he's doing his Huntsville Huntsville
done that I have I have awesome yeah is
that the one near the the space station
yep uh Bowling Green Kentucky guy pack
then uh you're in Cincinnati Taft
theater in the temple theater in
Shipshewana Shipshewana Indiana is home
of uh all Amish people wow I'm big with
them are you no no electricity no power
that's great yeah
blue gay theater sold out let's go baby
by the way my conversion tour starts
with John can you come on hey any of
these any of these shows if you guys
want to do just it's just got to be
clean I'll do it I would love you we
would we would they would love you they
would love I'd be into that I need to go
come through the material
I've seen both the olive zanies and like
Lucy loves both of you guys I'm gonna be
down there in March if you want jump on
well I always feel myself the worst the
worst the worst you could ever do is in
introduce yourself to another comic to
say you're a comic they haven't seen
your material or know you yeah like
someone goes like I'm a comic oh God
yeah doesn't do it right yeah yeah hey
I'm also a comic oh great so if you
don't know I'm not I'm never gonna come
into the Green Room be like hey well I
will now but well there's my definitely
do now boss Masters left Boston I'll be
there for New Years Awesome by the way
yep yeah that's great have you done mic
drop Comedy Club it's a new club in uh
San Diego January five six seven fourway
in Indiana Summit Comedy Club January 13
14 Dania Florida awesome club too yeah
then I got March uh I'm off uh to about
January 14th I'll have a special
announcement big Canadian tour coming up
in January but forget all that your
boy's taking a break from the road till
mid-January but fight companion we
partnered up with bar stool Sports we're
doing the rough and rowdy 19 uh they're
in Providence Rhode Island but we're
doing a hell of a crew I didn't mean to
cuss we're doing a heck of a crew all
right it's back to actually Brian you're
back in yeah it's all right we're doing
a
I'm sorry uh December night this Friday
for rough and rowdy combat's fight
campaign live on thick boy YouTube It's
Theo Von Donald Cerrone and Rampage
Jackson and myself let's go you can tune
in live it's bar stool thick boy collab
Saturday fight companion 7 P.M Pacific
Live on thinkable YouTube Brian Callan
Sam tripley and a very special guest
very special very special guest the MLB
quality thick boy jerseys just restocked
go get them right now thickboy.com and
that sweet nectar is available as well
uh John we love you dude can I come to a
fight with you guys I've never been to
one and you also go to a companion with
us oh I'll come through yeah we drink
though do you watch do you watch I mean
not everyone does I'm just kidding
that's fine you watch fights yeah I've
watched a couple what's your sport or uh
I watch football basketball they land
Hawks are my team I've never been to a
fight though so I got to get into it all
right what's the way to start
we'll go to the workshop then I'll be in
it's like a NASCAR race I go to tons of
those if you come you're like I'm in for
life and your college team says George
is not Georgia Tech that's unfortunate
yeah great for academic share National
Title 1990 with the Colorado Buffs you
guys stole it uh we just got uh Dion
Sanders let's go come on we love you
dude all the time